you're about to hear something you've
never heard before and something you
will never forget even if you live to be
a trillion I'm here with my main man
Eric Hernandez who is the author of The
Lazy approach to evangelism a simple
guide for conversing with
[Music]
non-believers the
lady you're of Mexican heritage aren't
you Eric I am proudly
yes and you went with the
lazy
approach ER quick quick quick question
um if you were French would you make a
book
titled the smelly cheese gobling French
losers guide to evangelism well no
because I'm not French if you were Irish
would you make the drunken
irishman's guide to evangelism or
something like that
it' be kind of a stereotype right
Mexicans are hard workers hard workers
just wanted to be clear on that we want
everyone out there to know that so
anyway I recommended uh uh a different
title a title change if Eric wanted to
lean into his Mexican heritage I
suggested how to beat an atheist like a
Piata bad and didn't want to go for that
but as we were brainstorming ideas for
how his book can be less racist is uh we
came up with an approach which we
call the taco
approach the T is for
teleological Eric give us one of the
many teleological Arguments for the
existence of God yeah so you've got a
few uh teleology basically means uh in
first design and you have the fine
tuning of the universe that in order for
life to exist the parameters need to be
so fine-tune and if they were just off
by a hair's margin nothing no life at
all would exist and so we can look at
something like that and the idea is we
can detect signs of design there that's
right and as you pointed out there there
are other versions of there there there
versions that are based on biology and
complexity of DNA and complexity of life
and things like that all kinds of them
in ch chemistry biology physics and so
on and so the
gist this Taco if I saw it and I had
never seen a taco in my entire life at
any point I could look at it examine it
carefully and realize that it is
designed the shell the meat the tomatoes
the cheese the hot
sauce they don't form like this by
Nature they have to be put in this
formation by a
designer that is chology Taco
chology A is for axiological the
axiological argument uh most common form
that we're familiar with is the moral
argument but give us an example of an
axiological argument for the existence
of God so you have uh one of the
traditional formulations um today is
that if God does not exist then
objective moral values and duties don't
exist but objective moral values and
duties do exist therefore God exists and
the reason being in a nutshell is that
when you look at the properties of
morality you see things that you know
it's something necessary Universal
Transcendent not dependent on us um and
you look at the properties of morality
um they're intrinsic to persons not
objects tables and chairs are not loyal
or kind persons are so if morality
exists it must be grounded in something
necessary personal and Transcendent
namely something like God and so imagine
Eric has a taco and I want that taco can
I brutally murder him and just take his
taco from him or would that be
objectively
wrong why would it be wrong to murder
Eric Hernandez for that
taco is is it just culture could it
change from one culture to another is it
is it our personal preference is it our
feelings or is it objectively morally
wrong if it's objectively morally wrong
then there is some sort of lawgiver who
makes that a rule and who is
that C is for
cosmological what would a cosmological
argument for God's existence look like
and again this is another argument where
there are multiple forms of it over the
centuries give us one um so again you
know using Craig um everything that
begins to exist has a cause the universe
begin to exist therefore or the universe
has a cause now to unpack the profundity
of the argument um in philosophy causes
are logically prior to external to and
greater than their effects so the person
that uh caused this U phone to exist or
the camera to exist doesn't exist inside
of it doesn't exist inside of the phone
and so if time space and meta had a
beginning you're going to need something
Transcendent time space and matter so
something that would have been Timeless
spaces and material something unimagined
powerful Transcendent and personal uh to
have the decision to create something
out of nothing and thus once again you
have something like
God so this
Taco had a beginning I'm going to give a
quick series of disjunctive syllogisms
ladies and gentlemen either this Taco
had a beginning or it has existed
forever it hasn't existed forever
therefore this Taco had a beginning
since it had a beginning we have another
disjunctive syllogism either this Taco
began to exist as a result of some cause
or it began to exist uncaused it's
absurd to say that it began to exist
uncaused therefore this Taco had a cause
and as Eric did you can expand upon the
sort of cause that would account for
this taco and as we've seen you can do
that with the entire universe
O is for
ontological lots of different
ontological arguments famously by people
like anel uh pla has offered ontological
arguments but give us an example of an
ontological argument for the existence
of God yeah to simplify CU it can get a
little complicated but essentially the
entire argument hinges on the premise if
it's possible that a maximal great being
exists so in philosophical terminology
if I say it is possible a maximal great
being exists I I'm essentially saying
that there is a possible World in which
there is this thing we call a maximal
great being but once you allow that then
by definition a maximal great being is
going to exist necessarily in every
possible world including the actual
world so if it's possible a maximum
great being exists then necessarily a
maximum great being exists in the actal
world if it's possible then a maximally
great being uh if it's possible that a
maximally great being exists that means
a Max maximally great being exists in a
possible world and a maximally great
being that exists in a possible world
would exist in all worlds that's right
or it wouldn't be maximally great that's
right so imagine a maximally great
taco these are the sorts of objections
that atheists raised to the ontological
argument for God because they don't
understand the argument so they would
say something like imagine a maximally
perfect island or a maximally Perfect
Taco guess what you actually don't have
a concept of a maximally great taco
there is no possible World in which a
maximally great taco
exists why because the properties that
make a taco great aren't the sort of
thing that you can just dial up to some
level of perfection like how how much
meat would there be in a maximally great
taco you could say infinity but then
it's not a perfect T how are you how's
anyone going to eat a an in a taco with
infinite meat in it or infinite lettuce
or infinite it doesn't work so it
wouldn't fit in a hand which is part of
what makes a taco great so you can
imagine a great taco you cannot imagine
a maximally great taco we have no reason
to think that something like that could
possibly exist and so the
characteristics of something like this
are different from the characteristics
that are involved in our concept of God
where you can have maximally great
goodness Max maximally great power
maximally great knowledge these are
things these are the characteristics of
a maximally great being and so we can
say a maximally great being is possible
and if it's possible in some world then
a maximally great being exists in all
worlds including
ours so whenever you see a taco from now
on remember the taco approach
bological
a axiological c
cosmological o ontological that is the
Taco approach every time you see a taco
every time you're eating a taco with
someone use this as an opportunity to
share these arguments and if you want
more be sure to grab the extremely
racist stereotypical lazy approach to
evangelism by our Mexican friend Eric
Hernandez
[Music]